Bonjour
Bonjour ?
Ah mais ça marche pas...
Ça marche ce truc ?
Est-ce que ça a marché ?
Bonjour !
Comment ça va en 2019 ?
Bien ?
Ici, à Abidjan, en l'an 2069,
pour tout vous dire ça va pas très fort...
C'est encore moi Vladimir Cagnolari qui vous parle,
après une tempête...
La tempête géomagnétique.
La plus forte depuis 1859,
quand une éruption solaire avait déjà
semer la zizanie sur terre en perturbant
le champ magnétique de la planète.
Mais à l'époque, évidemment il n'y avait
pas d'avion, encore moins de fusées,
l'électricité était rare et à part
quelques postes télégraphiques qui avaient pris feu,
faut bien le dire, il y avait eu plus de peur que de mal.
Mais imaginez-vous un peu en 2069,  pour vous dans 50 ans, là où je me trouve maintenant à Abidjan.
Oui, parce qu'ici, tout fonctionne
désormais avec les satellites les ondes
et même nos fameuses oreillettes GreenTooth...
Ah non là, pas maintenant non.
Voilà plus d'une semaine figurez vous qu'on a plus de courant,
plus d'ultranet, plus de moyens de communiquer,
les transports sont à l'arrêt, les banques,  les entreprises, la ville toute entière.
Et oui, sans technologie, sans les gadgets
qui se sont rendus indispensables, et bien on est déboussolé.
Alors du coup, bah on parle avec nos voisins pour se rassurer.
D'ailleurs hier j'ai tenté une sortie avec mon voisin de palier, pour faire une petite reconnaissance du quartier...
Un petit côté quand même...
Comme si tous le monde avait déserté après une catastrophe.
Post-apocalyptique...
Ouais, on rigolait mais en réalité on n'était pas très rassurés.
Tous les humains sont partis quoi...
Bon allez, faut je vous dise la vérité, ce que vous venez d'entendre ne date pas d'aujourd'hui.
J'étais bien à Abidjan, mais en 2019 au plateau qui à l'époque était encore le quartier les affaires de la mégapole ivoirienne.
Et la nuit, le plateau se vide !
On rencontre peu d'hommes, encore moins de piétons et on est seul au pied des gratte ciel
qui vous regardent de haut et semblent vous dire...
Hey petit...Qu'est qu'il y a ?
Si je me retrouvais là, c'était pour faire une ronde dans le quartier du plateau
avec l'architecte Issa Diabaté.
Pourquoi ?
Bah pour parler d'architecture, mais aussi d'urbanisme et des villes africaines d'hier et de demain.
Normal, à l'époque, en 2019,
je menais mon enquête sur les Afrofuturismes...
Au Burkina Faso, on a 70% de la population qui a moins de 30 ans.
Et quand tu réfléchis tu regarde que on a  qu'une seule porte de sortie...
C'est d'oser inventer l'avenir !
Aujourd'hui, je voudrais vous parler
non plus de musique, de romans, de sciences-fiction,
Mais bien de tous ceux qui très concrètement invente au quotidien le futur de l'Afrique.
Comme pour réaliser de grandes choses
et bien il faut commencer par les rêver.
J'ai repensé à Nkrumah, Kwame Nkrumah,
le premier président du Ghana indépendant...Je vous l'avais dit, pour moi c'était déjà un afrofuturiste !
Kwame Nkrumah, on le sait ,voulait à tout
prix faire de l'unité africaine une réalité.
il avait rêvé des états-unis d'Afrique.
Juste à côté de son pays, le Ghana il y avait la Côte d'Ivoire de Félix Houphouët-Boigny,
qui lui n'était pas d'accord hein !
Houphouët lui voulait faire les états unis d'afrique dans son propre pays la côte d'ivoire.
Oui, c'est vrai Houphouët pouvait bien être un brin mégalo, mais il voyait grand...
Il rêvait son pays, sa mégapole Abidjan
et même son village Yamoussoukro en
futurama...
Et c'est bien pour ça que j'ai demandé à Issa Diabaté, architecte à Abidjan, de me guider dans les rues du plateau
pour retrouver les rêves d'Houphouët.
Ses rêves qui ont fait ressembler le cœur de la ville à Manhattan,
mais surtout qu'ils ont fait ressembler à Abidjan !
Et pour mieux sauter prenons notre élan en remontant dans le passé.
Issa Diabaté.
s'adapte alors là on est dans le bas du
plateau ce qu'il faut savoir déjà sur
abidjan c'est que le ce qui a suscité le
déplacement de la capitale sur abidjan
c'est déjà les épidémies de fièvre jaune
de grand bassam et sur la copie inquiété
sur la coupe serait donc le site
d'abidjan a été choisi justement to run
en se lançant découpage lagunaire mais
son plateau et ce qui est intéressant de
noter sur le plateau c'est le bas du
plateau pendant lequel on est et le
début en fait de la ville blanche donc
la ville coloniale clavier au plateau et
qui s'est installée au plateau de façon
à pouvoir
surplombée en fait toutes les attaques
qui pourraient venir de la côte
donc il ya ce bras lagunaire qui coupe
la ville en deux ans fait en a 13
juillet d'un côté plateau de l'autre
avec les deux ponts qui l'a relayé
pendant très très longtemps en fait deux
parties de la ville où était relié que
par deux d'abord par un pont un premier
point était un pont flottant à la place
du confluent boigny et des sports
photons qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
pont qui flottent s'empresseraient
lagune qui permet aux voitures de passer
mais qui permet également à une certaine
heure de levée le pont ce qui fait que
la ville noire treichville était coupée
de la ville blanche et toute personne
qui était trouvée dans la ville blanche
passé la nuit au poste
donc déjà ça ça explique bien la
configuration de la ville d'abidjan ont
pas mal de milles coloniale sont basés
justement sur les aspects de sécurité
si vous prenez le nord du plateau par
exemple et le camp gbagbo qui est un
camp militaire donc toutes les attaques
qui pouvaient venir du nord d'abidjan
était stoppée net par l'autorité est
donc le plateau la ville blanche a
laissé ses deux langues en fait ils
avant cela
donc ça c'est important de savoir pour
comprendre là où on est après là où on
est en fait c'est l'une des premières
quartier du plateau qui est la partie
qu'on verse est donc la vue du chrono ce
qui l'est tout juste à côté qui justifie
sa position par rapport à la proximité
du port donc toutes les marchandises
transiter par la rue du commerce
d'ailleurs on voit dans l'architecturé
on va passer devant fait malheureusement
il a plu beaucoup on n'a quasiment plus
mais on voit encore la structure de l
architecture coloniale avec les
entrepôts malheureusement aujourd'hui ce
foncier est extrêmement valoriser donc
ça ne peut plus à ces deux entreprises
donc on va peut-être avancer j'ai aussi
après s'être écrasé
comment exercer son deuil on peut voir
les différentes époques larache tétouan
je plains tout et on peut essayer se
projeter parents d'élèves l'époque
coloniale en avait des échecs plutôt
comme celle-là avec e commerçants pas
toujours
en hauteur pour les entrepôts etc et
puis le logement malheureusement il y en
a de moins en encaisse qu'il disparaisse
à vue d'oeil
mais en même temps je trouve que c'est
ça qui reste le charme d'une ville comme
abidjan c'est de pouvoir lire les
différentes époques de façon
complètement mélanger et parfois presque
homogène en fait l'hétérogénéité oui
voilà il ya un certain nombre
d'architectes qui ont fait pas mal
l'expérimentation
l' architecture déjà à l'époque
bioclimatique
le milieu années 60 jusqu'au milieu des
années 80 ce qu'on appelle architecture
bioclimatique
alors c'est une architecture qui en fait
répond au climat c'est à dire qu'on est
dans un climat chaud surtout dans le sud
et qu'est ce qu'on va chercher à faire
dans un bâtiment c de la ventilation
notamment de la ventilation traversante
pour passer vers d'à côté à l'autre
qu'on crée une forme de confort
thermique mais avec l'avènement des
années 80 les vies ont changé les années
80 on a commencé à penser que la clim
aller tout résoudre que la voiture
allait résoudre tous les problèmes de
mobilité qu'il fallait juste investir
dans la technologie pour pouvoir avancer
mais on sent bien compte aujourd'hui que
ça ne fonctionne pas passer c'est une
vision qui a ses limites
donc même en architecture aujourd'hui on
parle de plus en plus architecture
bioclimatique c'est
complètement à la mode et mais très
souvent on oublie que c'est des choses
qui ont été expérimentées à la 50 ans
c'est à dire que vos futurs ici c'est
souvent le rétrocéder rétro futurisme et
complètement
je connais la peau que dis je te le
redis
mais bon
ici il ya des gens bien sous tous les
rapports
de belles routes goudronnées
des hommes sympathiques
jolies femmes
des enfants malades et sage à la fois
un bâtiment sis et
e
très intéressant qu'un bâtiment d'un
architecte s'appelle henrichon m
il ya beaucoup beaucoup construit
habitudes
dans d'autres capitales comme cotonou
comme addis abeba et dont la spécialité
en fait c'était pas tout ça était basé
sur qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que l'
architecture moderne en milieu tropical
alors par exemple là en face on à niveau
de l'alfa 2000
je sais pas si vous connaissez ce
immeuble à ses marrons une tour aussi
avec l'alluré de france en bas une
espèce d'arcade un peu à la sahélienne
aussi donc c'est des architectures même
si elles sont des tours qui ont des
aspects quand même assez moderne et
massive et massive où ils répondent
quand même à une vision de ce que c'est
que la tour en milieu tropical
il y avait ces préoccupations
bioclimatique comme titulaire mais il y
avait aussi j'ai l'impression l'idée
malgré tout au moins par morceau de
s'inspirer des cultures ou des
esthétiques africaine tout en faisant
des immeubles très moderne
absolument parce que ça c'est un petit
peu ce qu'on a perdu mais en réalité
l'intéressé quoi c'était réussi en
pratique en afrique on doit avoir une
esthétique qui parle de là où on vit est
justement par ce biais intéresser les
autres
si on doit tout simplement répliqué ce
que les autres en fait ça n'a aucun
intérêt
c'était quoi en fait l'idée de deux fois
bois ni dans les années 60 quand il a
commencé
a lancé tous ces grands travaux et
toutes ces tours ça va durer jusqu'à la
fin des années 80 je pense que la
différence par exemple entre abidjan et
dakar
c'est les visions des deux présidents je
pense que vous faut gagner
au sortir de la colonisation pour lui
c'était maintenant important d'avoir les
mains libres et d'expérimenter et donc
de faire des choses
qui se faisait donc sans complexe donc
des tours alors qu'on n'avait pas besoin
des choses assez monumentale
donc c'était sa vision et c'est ça qui
je pense nous donne encore abidjan ça
son peps et sa dynamique tandis qu'à
dakar on était plutôt dans dans la
culture dans la conservation dans le
patrimoine
donc on voit les choses à dakar on ne
voit plus abidjan et c'est intéressant
que ces deux capitales en plus qui sont
même s'ils sont distantes physiquement
115 relativement proches continuent
d'entretenir leurs différences voilà par
exemple on voit le haut rang de labatt
le sein de nervis qui ressemble en fait
à une espèce de de baobab en béton c'est
vrai il est il à cette forme là et en
même temps bon si on regarde ça avec
d'autres yeux ça peut aussi être le bas
d'une soucoupe qui s'envole c'est
complètement sauvages comme dans la
guerre des étoiles s'étaient
complètement ça mais parce que je trouve
qu'à l'époque souvent dans les années 60
on avait la modernité le futur c'était
également ses formes complètement
démente
on va voir tout de suite avec la pierre
au mythe
bel exemple comment elle a pu se lâcher
dans les années 70 en imaginant que le
futur c'était ça
l'icône du plateau
la mascotte du plateau jeep à la
pyramide
ok ce bâtiment
d'architecturé brutaliste forme de
pyramide stylisé avec quand même pour
l'époque un dessin très très audacieux
date des années
de 73 c'est un bâtiment qui a été fait
jeune architecte italien dont je me
souviens plus
mais qui est vraiment cette forme
complètement démente avec détails
c'est exceptionnel toute cette
couverture en lames d'aluminium pour
protéger justement mes fenêtres
alors malheureusement son temps c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les
il n'est pas suffisamment rentable pour
ce tout entretenir
ce qui fait qu'il est il est fermé
complètement la bande c'est vraiment un
super spermatique
il y avait des rumeurs qui disaient
comment il est rude mais on cherche
faut plutôt le sauver un élément de
patrimoine
voilà exceptionnel mais un pet cancan ou
au bois ni a laissé faire autant de
tours au plateau donc il y avait ce côté
nouvelle ère expérimentation mais c'est
pas calquer alors que pourtant il ya
beaucoup de liens entre la france la
côte d'ivoire comme entre la france et
son ancienne colonie
il sait pas calquer sur une architecture
qui ressembleraient à des choses
parisienne il avait nourri les états
unis c'est ça le plus qu'il a vu plus
pour lui ce que retenter la modernité
paris bâtiment aux manières ces dépenses
d'une certaine n'est pas nouveau pays
une nouvelle ère nouvelle vision on va
chercher ce qui se fait de mieux donc si
ces détours de ce sera début c'est ça la
vision en fait
fallait il fallait créer quelque chose
qui n'existe pas par son endroit par son
mélange par son audace c'est assez
étonnant parce que cas la pyramide
complètement à l'abandon ou encore à
travers ses fenêtres
des des stocks qui sont restés là
entreposés et puis juste à côté français
il ya un concert d'électro oui tout à
fait
vous ne me croirez peut-être pas mais
celui qui jouait ce soir là à l'institut
français au pied de la pyramide
eh bien c'était iba coulton je vous
parlais tantôt vous rappeler les
fistules
yens et d'un être humain
par exemple acquis inventer des
bâtiments aujourd'hui ce serait quoi
votre envie votre désir votre rêve
d'abidjan dans 50 ans ce serait qu'il en
soit une ville complètement verte une
ville on recommence à marcher ou une
ville on retrouve en fait une certaine
échelle humaine quelque chose qui habite
jaillit à 40
ça c est tellement je pense que c'est
des choses qui sont tout à fait possible
il suffit d'être inventif en fait dans
comment procèdent aujourd'hui on voit qu
abidjan et le problème d'abidjan en fait
tout tout sous ses problèmes de mobilité
c'est parce que j'avais déjà être
centralisées il ya encore de gros poule
qui centralise tout alors qu'on a besoin
un petit peu d'atomiser tous à écrire
des succession de mini vide les unes à
côté des autres pour pouvoir retrouver
un peu cette échelle humaine fait de
gérer un quartier avec la proximité en
fait comme dans les villages mais il ya
plein de village
exactement et
d
de la même façon qu'on doit s'appuyer
sur les techniques d'architecturé
ancestrale en fait ici ne sont jusque là
ces alimentations de différentes époques
on doit faire de même aussi pour la
construction d'un modèle social
quand on vend général qu'est ce qui fait
que les villages en fête championne
c'est que là d'éléments centrale n'est
jamais loin le chef est toujours présent
de toute forme ou une autre
donc il ya une forme de distance il
restait chez nous dès qu'on arrive en
ville le le lien avec ce titre
d'autorité devient complètement
immatériel votre vision de futurs allait
pas justement dans le ciel d'en
construire en montant de plus en plus
haut alors on est obligé de monter un de
plus en plus ne serait-ce que pour des
phénomènes de densification
il ya de la voile a pas de place ou même
je pense que vous utilisez la place
différemment quand on est effectivement
dans un habitat qui est plutôt collectif
on va libérer pas mal de places en fait
ce qui permet à tout le monde
justement d'avoir des jardins
suffisamment d'eau pour pouvoir les
partager partager 2000 3000 mètres
carrés dans le disque plante on est
encore dans une vision on découpe on
segmente c'est vrai on a chacun son
jardin pour soi et du tout petit mais
les tout-petits et je pense que des
logis d'habitat en vip doivent
effectivement verra à ce type de vision
donc pouvoir concentré l'habitat menée
lui permettre de jouir de grands espaces
so lu ment parce que ça permet également
de végétaliser
de baisser les températures se permet
d'imaginer autre chose que se déplacer
en voiture et du coup imaginer des modes
de vie complètement différent et je vois
que c'est des choses qui commencent à
émerger
plus on monte vers le sommet du plateau
plus les voitures se font rares et les
hommes aussi
on est au coeur de la nuit dans le
silence et on a vraiment l'impression
que les hommes déserté les lieux lundi
côté quand même comme site nippon comme
si tout le monde avait déserté après une
catastrophe post-apocalyptique donc tous
les humains sont partis quoi
on
germany cliquez ici
alors aujourd'hui c'est un jardin qui
qui sert aux gens qui travaillent pas
loin qui peut louer des hamacs et faire
la sieste entre midi et deux mais il
faut lui mais un mac même pour être tout
à fait rien ne se perd monnaie exacte
des termitières emprunt c'est une
termitière au milieu des buildings le
traditionnel et le moderne le passé le
futur qui coexistent dans le présente
franchement il n'est pas loin de
l'univers affront futuriste et on est en
tout cas dans ce mélange des genres et
des temps qui fait le charme de ce que
nous gagnons en tout cas depuis que les
urbains d'afrique sont devenus aussi
nombreux que les ruraux bien la question
de l'aménagement des villes est devenue
cruciale faite hier c'était déjà bien
longtemps qu'elle tout cas pour les
pouvoirs publics ce qui était à la mode
en 2019 comme solution c'était les smart
cities les villes intelligentes
oui après le smartphone la smart site
est connecté pour les services publics
privilégiant la technologie pour
simplifier la vie des habitants en
essayant d'avoir un impact minimum sur
l'environnement
or en 2019 il pleuvait des projets de
smart cité créée ex nihilo c'est à dire
à partir de rien le ghana avait ça hop
sidi la cité de l'espoir le nigeria est
qu atlantic city
le rwanda visionnent city le togo où
elle bing city elle cetera etc tout ça
en angola comme s'ils font ça pouvait
fait moderne aussi bon en tout cas tout
ça a été des grands projets qui en 2019
était pour beaucoup au stade de jolie
maquette sur cette question j'ai eu
envie de demander son avis à senna les
copies agbodji nous un jeune architecte
les togolais férus de technologie
consignes à tous à cannes avait soufflé
le nom cette année avait longuement
étudié les formes traditionnelles
d'architecturé il avait repéré la
cohérence des formes de l'objet du
quotidien à la maison de la maison au
jusqu'au village
oui les formes et leur esprit se
répétait comme si ceux qui les avaient
bâti suivait ce que senna mes appels
l'algorithme le vernaculaire un peu
comme si tous ces bâtiments africain
avec était qu'au départ les valeurs
fondamentales qu'on retrouvait à la fois
dans la pensée mais aussi dans les
musiques africaines et sur les smart
cité sénat mais ne s'en laissait pas
conter bonjour ya plusieurs pays
d'afrique c'est dernier temps que l'on
sait des projets de smart cities alors
d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est une smart
cities si vous voulez bien vous éclairer
là dessus et quel regard vous portez sur
ces différents projets de ville du futur
l'as marck cité faut faire très simple
et donc forcément gauche est un modèle
urbain dans lequel c'est la technologie
principalement qui fait la ville et
c'est donc la technologie qui construit
la ville c'est donc en quelque sorte en
retour en grâce de la technologie
puisque dans le modèle précédent qui
était la ville durable
on assimile un peu la technologie à
l'individualisme à de la pollution de la
chaire paix et la ville durable s'était
construit sur des systèmes très anti
technologique technophobes donc depuis
quelques temps la technologie devient la
chose qui fait la ville et cela pose un
certain nombre de problèmes il ya un
problème entre guillemets philosophique
presque qui est que les technologies sur
une venant incessamment et en même en ce
moment dans une sorte d ce potentiel
dans leur transformation
on peut se dire que la smart cité c'est
un horizon qui va toujours se défiler et
à peine en aura livré une projets de
smart citer que la technologie qui ont
servi à la faire seront déjà désuète et
que la ville elle-même serait caduc vue
que l'objectif de la smar cité ne peut
jamais être atteint parce que la
technologie changent en permanence
la technologie est donc une sorte de
vaste d'extraordinaire programme
d'obsolescence programmée est donc une
sorte de réalité en vie qui permet
devant de la technologie en permanence
et cela ce stick de façon très simple
par le fait que la sonorité en fête a
été conceptualisée par des gens qui
veulent vendre de la technologie et est
produit par des gens qui veulent vendre
de la technologie alors le deuxième
aspect le deuxième axe est la critique
que je fais de la smart cité c'est que
les innovations toujours eu pour
objectif d'augmenter l'homme
la première innovation en ce sens là a
été de trop les structures sociales et
lyon se sont mis en cause vont pouvoir
être qu'augmenter la tendance les
documents pilonnent avec la
technologique mais la technologie ne
prend pas au modèle de structures
sociales et va plutôt dans une direction
de se substituer au social et la
technologie va devenir social en quelque
sorte demain et cela pose un certain
nombre de problèmes par rapport à des
conquêtes comme les nôtres où les
structures sociales sont encore très
forte et il va falloir se demander est
ce que on peut basculer d'un classement
cité en gardant la complexité de nos
structures sociales africaines ou être
qu'on va accepter de voir en as marre
cité cette sorte de grosse machine de
transfert de la complexité de la
structure sociale dans de la
complexification technologique il ya un
an je dévie ligue nationale à se
positionner par rapport à cette question
là pour l'afrique mais c'est angèle a
sonné en afrique va attaquer le monde
entier puisque à cette échéance là où la
smac cité sera appelé m'ont fait qu sera
devenu en quelque sorte pour aller les
gars paul qui seront les plus grandes de
l'humanité et donc ce qui va se décider
en afrique va forcément avoir une aile
pas que de nouvelles oui il faudrait
voir à pas complètement cédé de manière
aveugle à 10 points
les fameuses smart cité est ce qu'elles
vont pas ressembler à ces smartphones
ces téléphones qu'on dit intelligent
mais qui ont tellement d'applications
qui servent à autre chose que de
téléphoner que ça mange toutes les
batteries égales afin et bah quand on
veut téléphoner smartphone est trop
fatigué oui il est tellement fatigué
qu'il ne peut même plus téléphoner mais
il reste la smart mais afone au jeu de
mots alors imaginez vous en cas de
tempête géomagnétique sur une smart cité
où tout est connecté
yep panique et puis enfin allait bâtir
de nouvelles villes ailleurs si c'est
bien mais c'est comme vouloir aller
coloniser mars
ce dont on a besoin nous les citoyens
des villes est bien c'est qu'on
réinvente la ville où nous sommes déjà
tous entassés pour que les centaines de
millions de gens qui habitent vivent
mieux voilà tout simplement quand même
toi comme le suggérait sénat mais le
plus marqué dans la sphère et bien c'est
bien celui qui fabrique et qui vend la
technologie zero 2019 il faut bien le
dire
rarement en afrique
quoi
abidjan 2069 la tempête magnétique a
fait de gros dégâts
on recommence à avoir l'électricité mais
de manière intermittente comme avant
avant à l'époque des délestages
vu la situation j'ai reçu la visite d'un
chercheur du bureau des voyages inter
temporaire là il m'a dit que ces ordres
été clair avec la crise il fallait
renvoyer dans le cloud tous les gens qui
appartenait à un autre temps et de là il
serait forwarder vers leur époque
d'origine
en gros on m'a fait comprendre que
j'allais rentrer en 2010 mais justement
à une époque où l'afrique se mêler grèce
de cette propreté un peu avant 2019
j'avais rencontré au burkina faso un
jeune homme
gildas qui est là qui misaient sur
l'avenir technologique de l'afrique
mais pour ça il fallait que chacun se
l'approprient cette technologie et sa du
plus jeune au plus vieux alors avec des
camarades
gildas a démonté ouaga là un lieu où
l'entraidé le partage des compétences
sont de mise pour trouver des solutions
aux problèmes de la communauté et c'est
grâce à ce genre d'initiatives qu'en
2000 69 50 ans plus tard l'afrique n'a
plus besoin de quelqu'un pour lui vendre
des technologies et autre cité toute
smart qu'elle soit lorsque je les
rencontrais gildas avait 30 ans et des
rêves qui épousait la réalité pour mieux
la transformer gildas oui le wagg à la
bhl c'est quoi d'abord le wagga lab
c'est un espace au fait
travail collaboratif et à la base au
fait on a voulu s'inspirer au fait de ce
qui était passé qu'on appelle chez nous
l'arbre à palabre c'est cet art ou les
assiettes se retrouver pour discuter
ensemble pour partager au fait tout ce
qui se passait dans leur zone
d'habitation pour essayer de résoudre
des problèmes qui touchent suter zones
d'habitation donc nous nous sommes
inspirés au fait de ce modèle a bien
voulu que les fab lab ont été inventés
au fait depuis les etats-unis et nous
nous sommes dit il faut monter un fab
lab qui répond à nos besoins donc ces
parties de l'arbre à palabres qui est un
modèle vraiment typique pour nous et on
se dit voilà il faut mettre un espace à
la disposition de la jeunesse pour
qu'ils viennent partager leur savoir
faire pour qu'ils viennent apprendre des
autres et petits viennent aussi pour
qu'ensemble on essaie de relever les
différents défis voilà et qui touche nos
quotidiens ou fait voilà alors justement
montreux mans un petit peu quelles sont
les réalisations sur lesquels vous avez
planché avec cela se voit ghalab sortir
qu'on a monté en 2013 donc on est parti
du boyau avant d'une moto où on a
construit une éolienne qui fait du 1
kilowatt heure il n'est pas pu ça mais
l'idée c'est de montrer qu'on peut
arriver avec de la récupération à faire
quelque chose d'utile et on va continuer
ici là c'est un séchoir un séchoir que
nous avons fait pour des bénéficiaires
c'est pour des femmes qui sont à
koudougou qui est la troisième capitale
c'est des femmes qui font de la
riziculture en train de travailler
puisque avec ça on a aussi des
apiculteurs
il nous en soulignant qu'une
problématique comment accéder à leur
réussite sans pour autant affecter les
abeilles sans pour autant se faire
piquer et eux ils ont utilisé une
technique qui était la torche qu'ils
utilisaient pour allumer est vrai que ça
fait face à la russe et les abbés suit
les rayons lumineux pour se déplacer
pendant pour bébé et a sûrement eu ils
interviennent et nous les a proposé de
faire une réussite à améliorer ça veut
dire une russie avec des bacs ou et le
bac un des sous on aura de la lumière et
des capteurs des détecteurs de lumière
et dès qu'il veut intervenir et à la
lumière qui va s'allumer et le détecteur
qui va ouvrir une porte les abeilles
vont descendre sur la deuxième case
après dés qu'ils fissent d'intervenir il
ya la deuxième but mais qui va s'allumer
en eau la porte va s'ouvrir et les
abeilles va le monter et dans le riche
au fait tu dis donc ça veut dire ça
vraiment que pour chaque problème
concret on essaye de trouver une
solution une solution de technologie
quoi et ça c'est comment est ok
ingénieur à la base oui je suis
ingénieur en informatique et télécom et
dacquois donc ce n'était pas du tout
dans l'apiculture
non non de la riziculture non je suis
pas du tout dans l'apiculture et de
l'agriculture mais c'est un domaine qui
me passionne beaucoup parce que je vois
un peu l'avenir pour moi aujourd'hui si
je vais parler de l'agriculture je
pourrais dire que nous avons les uns
cutter qui jusqu'aujourd'hui n'ont pas
pris ce domaine d'activité comme de
l'entrepreneuriat il y le frein jusqu'à
présent comme un métier de survie et
nous ne pensons qu'on peut aller au delà
tant qu' on arrive au fait d'aller
montrer qu'il ya des techniques
innovantes qui vont leur permettre de
pouvoir accroître voilà leurs méthodes
agricoles
dis moi là donc on est toujours dans
votre pièce c'est assez marrant parce
que moi il ya une grande table avec l'un
de chaises autour plein d'instruments il
ya des pistons des f1 les trucs
compliqués à des fers à souder ici au
fait c'est notre espèce de prototypage
et nous avons trois imprimantes 3d qui
valent à des imprimantes classique qui
permet d'imprimer au fait sur du
plastique et pourquoi ces imprimantes
parce qu'on s'est dit
aujourd'hui nous avons la technologie
qui avance et si nous voulons vous
faites ne pas être en retard de la
technologie est aussi permettre à nos
jeunes frères de pouvoir prendre le
train en marche parce qu'une bonne non
de plus réinventé la roue c'est de leur
permettre de pouvoir utiliser ces
nouvelles technologies la et de leur
père au dossier de s'imprégner de cette
nouvelle technologie afin qu'ils
puissent les records se voir pour les
réadapter à leurs propres besoins
et voilà donc nous avons trois
imprimantes 3d que vous avez fabriqué
intégralement vous même non moi je suis
plus mal mais la troisième imprimeur en
imprimer les pièces où les deux gt plus
même pour monter la 3e primaire
donc l'imprimante comme c'est la reprap
c'est une voisine qui serait produit
donc aujourd'hui suffit d'avoir une
seule imprimante et tu peux avoir dix
mille imprimantes après je vous avais
même un drone
ouais c est là on est en train de
construire un vrai c'est vous même qui
fabrique et oui celui là c'est notre
faute si vous cherchez à partie de lui
on espère faire plein de donne surtout
dans le domaine de l'agriculture qui
nous intéresse beaucoup pour faire quoi
vous faites il ya des drones parce que
on a vu il ya des caméras aujourd'hui
ou quand tu prends la vidéo où l'image
si tu donnes en même temps l'humidité la
température
nous nous voulons faire remonter nos
drones et puis mettre à ce type de
caméra pour pouvoir suivre voulu faire
des zones agricoles et en même temps
avoir l'image de la zone agricole aussi
bien que de la température et de
l'humidité et le but aussi c'est de
mettre ces données à la disposition des
agronomes qui va sensibiliser des
incultes et qu'ils soient dans ces zones
par rapport aux méthodes habitudes qui
sont adaptés à ces types là d'une zone
agricole
tu peux faire des navigations à distance
tu peux suivre l'évolution des plantes à
distance aujourd'hui même avec tossem
smartphones tu peux arriver à déclencher
des deux moteurs qui font arroser et moi
je pense que on devrait aller dans ce
sens et c'est vraiment une obligation
pour nous aussi on prend vraiment
l'agriculture comme une des sources de
revenus et au burkina faso 80 pour ça
nous sommes des agriculteurs donc et de
surcroît on n'atteint même pas le de
suffisance alimentaire pendant que 80 %
des agriculteurs samedi il ya quelque
chose qui va pas donc il faut vraiment
adapté cette nouvelle technologie est là
en tout cas adapter notre notre méthode
d'agriculture utiliser cette nouvelle
technologie
ça ne peut qu'être bénéfique pour nous
comment la fraiseuse oui la fraiseuse à
commande numérique au fait elle celle
inverse de l'imprimante 3d
elle découpe au fait donc ses découpes
de précisant où tu peux faire un modèle
voilà sur un modèle 2d et après c'est la
fraiseuse qui découpe au fait que
sérieuses commencent
aujourd'hui si on veut que vous faites
les plusieurs puces voilà sans cap à
l'est de cet outil numérique
il faut vraiment que ça paraît alain
yeux comme un outil banal dont la série
mettre ces vieux ordinateurs d'un débit
d'eau qui va susciter d'avoir la
curiosité des gamins qui vont se dire
mais écoutez un bidon on connaît bien un
bidon mais ce qui est à l'intérieur
c'est parce que c'est sa valeur restait
vraiment la curiosité des gamins
deuxième le permettre de connaître et de
comprendre les différentes parties au
fait de l'outil numérique et
troisièmement le remettre dans la tête
aussi que qui a décerné il pu arriver à
fabriquer leur propre ordinateur pour un
gamin quand il arrive à monter assembler
des pièces d'ordinateurs dans un bidon
il vient de fabriquer sont plus de
nature et ans qu'il a ça dans sa tête on
est vraiment sûr que c 'est les geeks de
demain et c'est eux qui vont réinventer
le numérique demain parce qu'ils n'ont
plus peur d'aller vers le numérique
ils se disent que s'ils saluent à
fabriquer leurs propres machines il peut
vraiment aller au delà de commenter les
faits ses ordinateurs
jerry khan à yahvé yes we can en fait là
on a un ici là on a réussi qu'on a monté
avec des jeunes gamme r on en a un autre
qui est devant l'algérie calvaire
c'était révolutionnaire son quart à
parler de oser inventer l'avenir y
lisait produire pour qu'ils n'avaient
consommé burkinabè
oui vous faites moi par rapport à cette
phrase j'avoue que c'est c'est une des
directions que nous avons pris au fait
parce que nous nous sommes dit au bout
de la face on a 70 % des blessures à
moins de 30
et quand tu réfléchis tu régate que et
on n'a qu'une seule porte de sortie
c'est d'oser inventer l'avenir et c'est
de s'auto employer
parce que pour moi un jeune avec un
ordinateur une connexion internet c'est
potentiellement une entreprise quelle
que soit où est ce que tu es tu es une
entreprise ambulante oser inventer
l'avenir
est-ce que c'était pas là l'un des
slogans de thomas sankara un autre afro
futuriste et grand rêveur devant
l'éternel
sans rêve pas d'avenir et la future in
c'est notre capacité à réinventer notre
futur que notre futur ne soit fut jamais
uniquement celui imaginé la maison celui
qui n'est pas en capacité de se projeter
dans le futur c'est pourquoi pas des
j'aime le changement aujourd'hui en
afrique sont très visibles et ça c'était
également un message porteur d'avenir
parce qu'on a cette image omniprésente
de jeunes africains qui ont l'impression
que leur avenir est forcément hors du
continent mais c'est bon d'avoir de le
prêter c'est imad également d'une
jeunesse qui est là qui à tous les
problèmes du move qui s'est dit et bien
ces problèmes résolus journée et pour
les résoudre
regardons les technologies et adaptons
les ces problèmes
la productrice à dents tout pour moi et
politique
la politique ça n'est rien d'autre que
le vivre ensemble
la politique ce n'est pas un programme
politique et étatique
c'est d'abord comment est-ce qu'on veut
vivre ensemble et comment est ce qu'on
peut vivre ensemble et de ce point de
vue là la fauv tourisme assume et
réengage ça au penser le futur on est
obligé de repartir aux traditions on a
obligé d'aller rechercher les outils du
traditionnel pour revenir les colorées
avec des couleurs et une peinture
moderne quoi
mélissa si je te dis afro futurisme
qu'est ce que tu me dis in future wii
existe chers amis ça va être la fin de
ma transmission la dernière j'en ai bien
peur je m'apprête à vous retrouver en
j'ai caché mon oreillette green tous
dans la poche et j'espère pouvoir
l'emporter avec moi qui sais pas ce
qu'elle me permettra peut-être de
pouvoir déposer le brevet avant tout le
monde
en tout cas je ne sais pas de quoi
demain sera fait mais j'espère que
d'autres peut-être vous qui m'écoutent
et vous aurez l'occasion de voyager dans
le futur et de raconter
et puis si c'est pas le cas alors il ya
de quoi dans le présent raconter les
projets de tous ceux qui rêvent et en
semences le futur de l'afrique
je suis sûr qu'une radio comme rfi sera
intéressé par le sujet car comme disait
binda sans rêve pas d'avenir
avant de finir s'ils sont l écoute jean
voit un grand merci à six dates ou ça
casse' monde creuse qui m'ont aidé à
réaliser ce rêve afro futuriste portez
vous bien erraient l'effort moi je coupe